what's going on everybody welcome to
another Django tutorial video in this
video what we're talking about is
styling so we can break websites down
into a lot of aspects but generally
you've got more of the backend which
sometimes is confused with like server
back-end but really what we mean by
back-end is something that isn't
presented to the user and then you've
got front-end this is the actual user
interface so the UI UX so user interface
user experience and so generally there's
quite the dichotomy here and people that
are good at the backend or the website
logic let's call it are not generally
very good at the user interface so this
can be kind of a challenge if you're a
programmer who wants to get into web
development but you are not a designer
you don't know much about HTML CSS and
all that so luckily there is bootstrap
so bootstrap is it's hard to explain it
right out of the gate but basically it
provides you with mainly a CSS style
sheet or a CSS so cascading style sheet
and some JavaScript includes that you
can use on your website and then it also
gives you HTML snippets that you can you
can make use of on your website and
basically what it does for you is it
allows you to have a nice responsive
decent looking website very fast so some
examples of my websites that are
bootstrap would be like sent XCOM this
is all bootstrap I didn't really write
and I mean I wrote some of the HTML but
all the CSS is it's just bootstrap okay
it's like all that stuff's bootstrap
then we've got Python programming net
the actual web the tutorials website
it's all bootstrap okay so once you
start to learn bootstrap you'll begin to
see that like a lot of websites are
using bootstrap you'll start seeing it
everywhere so with that let's go ahead
and get started so what are your going
to do with bootstrap you can go to get
bootstrap comm one thing to note a
bootstrap does have a content
livery Network it's not here but I'll
show it to you later well we'll click on
download bootstrap so first go to get
bootstrap comm go to download bootstrap
sure enough here's the information on
the CDN if you're not familiar with a
CDN the idea of a CDN or content
delivery network is to help your
website's load quicker so initially you
may not think that 100 milliseconds here
100 milliseconds there really matters
but it does it makes a big difference
and a lot of times your users don't even
realize that it makes a difference to
them but the faster your website there's
been plenty of studies shown it makes
the user experience way better if you
can if you could make it instant that's
the most ideal thing right so this is
the CDN you can use that if you want and
it will basically it'll just allow your
the CDN basically has like servers let's
say and a bunch of locations and the
server that is closest or quickest for
your user to access that's the server
that will send the data for prefer let's
say in this case is the CSS sheet or the
CSS and and there's other stuff too like
this is for the JavaScript and stuff
like that so you can use a CDN in this
tutorial I'm actually going to show us
running the code locally because it'll
allow me to actually show you guys how
to handle static files which I mean like
all your files you're not going to be
able to have a CDN unless you make the
CDN and if you're watching this tutorial
chances are you have no idea how to do
that anyways so the first thing we're
going to do is talk about static files
and where to store them so anyways with
CDN in mind we're going to actually
download bootstrap instead so you come
here and just download bootstrap you
don't want the source code you don't
want sass you want bootstrap once you
have bootstrap downloaded you should be
able to come here and you know got the
zip or whatever so go ahead and extract
it and then open up this distribution
and you've got CSS fonts and JSO
javascript so let me move this aside
we're done in the downloads and move
this over and now in my site now you can
have a static directory just like
templates a static directory per apps
as you can imagine there may be some
images that are specific to that app
also your website's main app is also
probably going to be where you reference
all of your CSS okay but you could
reference or at least your main CSS page
let's say you might have custom CSS per
app but your main apps CSS probably in
your main your main website so every app
is probably not going to have separate
CSS if it's all with the same website
anyways so we're going to go into
personal and then we're going to make a
new directory and we're going to call it
static now with the stuff that we just
downloaded I'm going to highlight it and
move it into static so now within static
we've got CSS and we've got all these
CSS keep want to say CSS Sheets but
right there cascading style sheets so
CSS sheets would be cascading style
sheet sheets anyway um the main one that
we're interesting is right here
bootstrap mndot CSS that's the one we're
actually going to reference the other
ones you can have here it's not going to
make a big difference because we're not
referencing them anyways also I think
here we've got fonts this is mainly for
glyph icons which we'll talk about here
in probably a moment and then the
JavaScript these are just some
JavaScript stuff so various like
popovers and maybe like notification
kind of dialogues the modal's stuff like
this are going to be using JavaScript
also like drop-down menus stuff like
that so if you want to reference that
you have to you know reference these but
we'll talk about how to do that here in
a moment
we have a static directory templates
requires it static requires it if you're
old-school
django you may have actually had to hard
code where to find static if you're
using a later version you probably don't
but just to make sure you are
referencing the static directory you go
back to my site and then the my site the
main kind of my site directory here so
my site slash my site settings that PI
go ahead and edit that with idle and
make sure that you have the Settings
directory it's probably at the very
bottom right here static URL equals
static you can also visit this for some
some information but you should be
you'll get it from me anyway so just
like templates when you reference a
static file it's going to automatically
assume it's in slash static and just
like templates you
have a slash static directory for all of
your installed apps Django is just going
to mesh them all together so for the
same reason you may want to lead them
off with a personal directory now that's
basically all we need now we've got that
in now how might we actually reference
those files so first of all let me talk
real briefly about bootstrap generally
what I recommend people do the first
time you come to see bootstrap and then
also every time you start a project I
usually go to get bootstrap comm and
then you know hold control CSS
components Java scripts right click
these three tabs you can also go to
customize if you want because you can
customize bootstrap you know various
ways down here but mainly we're
interested in these tabs and then in
these tabs you can see oK you've got
these are like basically your I can't
think a table of contents I suppose and
actually quite a good table of contents
I really like this I'm actually I'd like
to steal the code from that the
basically I usually come to these
website or these pages and just kind of
scroll through looking for stuff that
looks interesting like oh I might want
to make use of this grid system so noted
and then you can kind of keep scrolling
down and you got components these are
those glyph icons so a lot of times you
want to use an icon these are a bunch of
free icons that you can use in your
website but then there's all kinds of
stuff so then you got dropdowns and but
button groups and buttons you've got nav
bars so here's an example of a navbar
that they build the code and basically
all this stuff like shows you what it
would look like how you would interact
with it and then this is actually the
code that you can just copy and paste to
your website and then kind of modify it
a little bit to be exactly what you want
anyway you can keep scrolling down there
and then javascript is another good one
that you want to scroll down or because
they add they do add stuff over time so
you're going to find that you've got new
you know new additions as time goes on
which is why it's always a good idea to
revisit it plus some stuff that you've
never used before maybe something you
might want to use now so like for
example here's a modal so this is why
it's JavaScript you click this and then
you get this like pop-up kind of stuff
so
anyway that's what this is and to get it
you would copy and paste this code
modify to your liking and so on just a
bunch of information there so we're
going to I'm going to leave this aside
for now
and we're going to go into our website
and talk about how we can at least
include include our static files in our
CSS page so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to go into personal
templates personal and the header file
so again the header file is what's going
to encase basically all of our other
HTML files for the most part so in here
this is where we want to load in our CSS
so generally your CSS is going to be
loaded in in in the head of your header
let's say so to do that what we're going
to do is we're going to first what we
need to do is we need to load the static
files so the templates didn't really
require this but within here we we do
need to load in all available possible
static files so first we use a little
bit of ginger logic here and we say load
static files what this does is it tells
Django hey get ready I'm about to
reference a static file and I want to be
able to reference the static files so
gather up your own list of static files
so you know what I'm talking about when
I reference it so you only need to call
this once and especially if you're
calling it in your header file that
means it's being called on all your
other files anyways so you just need to
call it one time
you shouldn't have to like call it every
time you want to reference a static file
so now we're going to say is link the
relation here is it's a stylesheet and
the basically the reference for this
stylesheet is and then here's where like
normally you would give the path like
let's say like on flask for example our
style sheets were stored in slash static
of our website so you would say slash
static CSS and then maybe bootstrap
boots tree bootstrap min dot CSS okay
that might be a way to reference it and
if you were familiar with flask actually
you could use you could make this a
variable and make it very dynamic same
thing is true in Django just slightly
different
so instead of hard-coding it we can do
this so the reference will be the static
directory and then from that static
directory
it was located in CSS actually let's go
back I don't think I did that uh let's
go to templates
what's it personal static okay I did do
it for the same reasons that we did this
before you probably actually don't want
it to be in just straight-up static it
could go either way here because
generally at least this information this
is the CSS that we're going to use on
the whole website very rarely does like
a website have custom CSS where that
custom CSS completely replaces the other
CSS so sometimes on some pages you're
going to load a local stylesheet so
something that kind of appends the
existing style sheet so you still
actually will reference the main
stylesheet so in this case in the case
of CSS fonts and JavaScript I don't
think you have to have like a personal
static personal CSS fonts JavaScript you
can do whatever you want if you want to
add it go for it one thing that I would
recommend like later on when we have
like an images directory
I really would suggest you do personal
images and then go in or even images
slash personal slash whatever the thing
is but for the CSS fonts in JavaScript
this is something that's going to apply
to all pages they you probably could be
you'll be just fine this way so anyway
CSS slash bootstrap CSS okay easy enough
then we finally add our type equals text
slash CSS close off that tag and we're
done so now we've referenced the style
sheet before I save this however let's
go up to here and let's run the site
real quick I don't think I have it up
anywhere so yeah let's pull it up it's
not running so then so now you're going
to do a managed up high run server so
a Python managed up I run server servers
running you pull it up so here's our
current website you everything's very
basic so then what I'll do is we'll come
back to this header tab and close these
out or the header HTML file save that
we're including the stylesheet now come
back here refresh and a couple of things
you'll notice the the text is different
it's also not pure black it's like a
very dark grey also the edges are kind
of gone there that's okay
anyway but bottom line we see that
indeed we have apparently loaded up a
stylesheet we can view the source real
quick and we can indeed see that for the
stylesheet again it's not you're not
we're not seeing the ginger logic here
it's the actual HTML so in theory the
user can take this static link click it
and sure enough that's our HTML or well
our style sheet so so anything you have
in static just keep in mind that's all
publicly available ok so you want to put
anything that needs to be secret in your
static directories so let's close this
out I'll zoom out again and so now we
have just some simple stuff so like
let's let's kind of improve our homepage
a bit so kinda like before I don't see
much point in this like hand coding our
our HTML here so what I'm going to go
ahead and do is I'm going to copy and
paste HTML from this the tutorial so go
to the link in the description to get
the code otherwise we'd spend about 30
minutes writing out this HTML and I
don't want to do that to you find
individuals so I'm going to literally
copy and paste it over here again go to
the description to get the code and now
I will explain it here in a second so
let's I'm going to save that and I'm
going to come back to the website and
refresh make sure everything worked and
let me come back here
did I okay yeah so in the code in the
sample code I did have this personal
again it really doesn't matter if you
get this though it's a good chance I can
good time for me to reference it also I
have a face that I don't have here so
any time you get this right obviously
our CSS is not here what the heck
happened we can view the source we can
see okay this is where it's trying to
reference let's check it out it's not
there doesn't exist so we know that's a
problem and then here we can see image
source static personal image profile jpg
that also doesn't exist so what the heck
so we can come back to our code and
let's say we do want to do the whole
personal thing so we could say is new
folder personal CSS fonts JavaScript
drag that into personal click that cool
we obviously don't have that image yet
but then let's come back over to our
website let's refresh and sure enough
we've got pretty much everything we need
we're just missing this face jpg so let
me pause here and let me grab face real
quick okay grab this profile picture
here and come over here and it's
actually profiled a jpg so personal
image profile dot jpg so we're
impersonal we'll make an image directory
here ing move the profile picture into
there and finally our website should
word let's pull it up 127 there we go
alright so obviously we're not winning
any any awards for this website but it
at least looks okay so let's explain the
code real quick so coming over here zoom
out or scroll out a bit so again this is
the head the head basically it just
gives the the browser some information
okay so so here this is just the title
the tab you can look at your tab and see
yep sure enough this gives the character
set utf-8 then we load the static files
we load up the CSS page that's simple
this is a meta tag basically this is for
bootstrap okay so the idea of bootstrap
is to be very
mobile-friendly okay so so with
bootstrap we've put in some pretty basic
HTML here but you can see it's like this
is like a computer screen but if we
squish up the screen you'll see that
everything works it just it'll just work
out in your favor okay in most cases
anyway so so you could view this on a
phone or a website or a phone or website
a phone or like a computer and it looks
okay
okay so then we pop into the body here
and we start to see okay it's a div
class container fluid that's a bootstrap
specific container basically it's going
to be a nice mobile friendly container
and we're giving this a minimum height
of 95% the reason why we're getting away
with this is because of this little
style edition that we're making so again
with like you might have like style
sheets just like this where it kind of
appends on top of this style sheet but
you're still always going to reference
this one first anyway this just says the
page is 100% tall so the reason why
we're doing that is for this footer this
isn't the best way to do this by the way
it's just the easiest way so this footer
as you can see it kind of comes up or
down as you move the page around so
eventually it but it won't it won't roll
over these other divs so basically this
is as good as it gets once you start in
conflicting with this other div it's not
going to let you do that but anyway
that's just our way of making the page
always like a full page right no matter
kind of where you put it so it's kind of
neat anyway that's why we're doing that
then you get to these rows well the rows
are the bootstrap grids let me pull
these over so this is an example of the
grid so that's here so these stacks
grids this just tells you basically a
grid has rows and then you can say
column sizes the maximum width is 12 so
you can have a bunch of ones that add up
to 12 you might have an 8 and a 4 or 4 4
4 or 6 and a 6 and so on and that's your
way of styling them as usual these are
also dynamic and and mobile-friendly so
if the page was squished up a bunch no
problem it handles for that so those are
that's just like one example
of what we're using in our case we're
doing a 2 and then 2 10 the 2 is
containing basically to start our little
profile image and/or banner and stuff
like that we get down here we start a
new row and then this one contains these
nav pills so again we can look at this
and well so these would be like our
NAB's so this is in components you come
to NAB's there's tabs there's pills and
all this stuff refresh here there we go
so this is the beginning of that NAB's
also we've got our nav bar that's
contained within a well there's the code
it's just a special do with kind of a
dark doubt background you can customize
that background however you like though
in our case we sure enough have
customized that background because
actually we made the background white
and then the background of our website
our entire website is actually a darker
color so we did that here so we've got
the Navajos and containers I think we're
all set now actually yeah so everything
else is done we have footers and a
footer tags with html5 um we got some
extra tab or tags like nav and footer
and body and header and stuff like this
header and footer just can correspond to
your website's header and footer may be
the body content header and footer stuff
like that you don't actually have to
contain them in tags that are header and
footer and stuff it's just a good idea
so like something like google as they're
crawling your website just makes it
really easy for Google to understand
what's going on and what the information
is and means and stuff so that's really
the basics of the website broken down
into two what we've got going on if you
have any more questions about how I'm
doing something here feel free to ask
another thing that I just thought I
would show you um is like this this div
with the sidebar fixed so this line can
replace this line let me just zoom it in
now that we're not talking about macro
stuff so what I can do is comment it out
and if you're not familiar to comment
stuff it would be like it's an opening
sign I don't know what to call that
exclamation mark - - blanking on the
word someone's going to make fun of me
and then you close off the the comment
like that so let's open this one up just
to show you guys so we can fix that
sidebar so although we don't have
content but all I had some content
refresh and it looks identical and what
we could do just to show is let's go
into a personal templates personal home
whoops
shouldn't on that I want to edit it
notepad and then like I'm just going to
copy this paste paste paste and then
copy paste paste paste registration okay
so it's nice long homepage and we can
refresh and now as we scroll our little
nav bar stays in place so that's pretty
cool but what ends up happening is the
following
so if when we're up here everything's
kind of rolling over it right because
this is a navbar that moves like with
this stuff so obviously that's messy you
want something that's going to be
totally responsive so that would be an
example of a mistake
so as you're developing it's always a
good idea to check various sizes and try
to mimic screens if you are in Chrome
one thing that's pretty cool you can
press f12 and go into I believe it'll be
sources no let's see element maybe this
one there we go so this little screen up
here you can toggle device mode we'll
just make it fullscreen here and you can
mimic what your website will look like
on various devices so we can see on
whatever this device happens to be let's
try an apple ipad okay that looks pretty
cool let's try a blackberry okay that
looks pretty cool fine jumpy like a
phone man
iPhone 5 it still looks pretty good it's
not bad I suppose but we should be
getting that overlay I'm not sure why
we're not getting it because we still do
have that problem with the div here but
let me comment that one out because I'm
not going to actually use it and open
this one back up but you can't even come
here and look at what it looks like on
various devices the other thing that you
can do is and then also like obviously
this is like your finger so like you can
mimic clicking things with your finger
and doing this and that and the other
thing anyway so there you go yes for
some reason now it's actually loading as
it as you might expect it's really as
weird before it was like really zoomed
out that's just not the way it would be
but you can also like use your phone
right and visit it with your phone and
make sure everything works also you can
test the speed on your phone and stuff
like that so obviously as long as you're
developing locally though like if you
try to visit this locally that's not
going to work but once you actually have
like something that you can either host
locally on like an actual like IP like
your local IP or even your website every
time you push an update or something
like that you should periodically check
it on your phone to make sure things are
working as you might expect I'm going to
close out of this now and I guess let's
move this over so anyways that's all for
this tutorial if you have questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below in the next tutorial
we're going to start actually building
out our website means the amount here
and so as you can see we've got a home
page blog and a contact page so all that
stuff is something that we actually want
to build here so that's we're going to
be doing as we progress through these
tutorials so anyways as always thanks
for watching things for all the
supportive subscriptions
until next time